las enfermeras y los médicos de las
unidades de cuidados intensivos de este
hospital del sumo no ven decaer la
actividad desde mediados de diciembre
una nueva oleada de contagios obligó a
francia a endurecer nuevamente las
restricciones pero los pacientes siguen
llegando y los trabajadores de la salud
temen que lo peor puede estar por venir
estamos un poco ansiosos de que en un
par de semanas tal vez las cifras suban
ya que eso es lo que los institutos de
salud están pronosticando así que
estamos contando mucho con las vacunas
pero entonces esta enfermedad nos ha
enseñado que a veces tenemos que dejar
de hacer pronósticos y tratar de
mantener lo que sabemos y adaptarnos a
los acontecimientos
la atención hospitalaria obliga a los
trabajadores de la uci a atender no sólo
a los pacientes con kobe 19 sino también
a los que son tratados por otras
enfermedades por lo cual según el jefe
la salud mental de sus trabajadores se
está deteriorando
si esa crisis nos ha cambiado a todos ha
habido estudios que han demostrado que
ha atraído mucho estrés estrés
postraumático problemas para dormir
entre algunos a veces ha traído mal
humor a veces ansiedad
probablemente nos ha cambiado a todos y
todos estamos un poco preocupados por lo
que será de nosotros cuando todo esto
termine
en medio de los temores que desata la
presencia de una nueva variante del
coronavirus más contagiosa según los
expertos francia ha visto como la
cantidad de personas en si ha superado
las 2800 por primera vez en un mes las
vacunas apenas han llegado a cerca de
500 mil personas y las autoridades no
descartan un nuevo confinamiento si la
situación sigue empeorando